it contains an oven a microwave a laser
and the core developed by the US
Department of Defense as you may have
gathered this is no ordinary timepiece
this is the world's first commercially
available atomic watch and it's atomic
for a reason what makes the atomic watch
special is that it's the most accurate
watch in the world it tells the right
time to one second every thousand years
london watchmaker richard won't be
selling it to just anyone though if
taken apart the number 16 could have
military uses and so buyers have to be
vetted inside though you won't find
anything nuclear you'll just find a
cesium gas chamber encased in an oven
heated to 130 degrees a laser to excite
the atoms and a microwave resonator to
measure time actually the microwaves
just get the frequency out to wrap
around a large atomic chip Joule dials
also display moon phases sunrise an
equation of time and five other
complications this is amazing
I think the technology inside is quite
amazing tool atomic time is limited if
you want to buy one that is only a
hundred are being produced with a 15,000
pound price tag for the gold version
I would my one because basically the
accuracy that he's built into this watch
sort of trails into his other watching I
mean he's also made some of the most
accurate quartz watches around and the
only way to calibrate those watches is
with the atomic one being two hundred
and fourteen thousand times more
accurate than Britain's most famous
clock pot trough may have called time on
the ancient quest for accuracy by
watchmakers the world over